This is something that just came up and
we were trying to figure out if it's
nonsense or not.
My friend Adam was here the other day
and we're talking about Toyota trucks and
he didn't Google Toyota
trucks just discussing it.
And he said since then his mentions
had been filled with these little
advertisements for Toyota trucks.
How's that work?
Well, you know how you talk
to Siri? Yes. Um, it, it's,
it's simple voice rec
recognition. It, it's,
it's a carry over from the old days
of, you know, optical readers and how,
you know, we all thought it was incredible
that you could take a piece of paper,
put into a system and it would like take
that information that was on that piece
of paper and now it was on a database
that you could access and manipulate.
And so, you know, voice recognition is no
different in the sense that, so if, if,
if,
for example,
if I had this switched on and
it happens to people on the,
I'm sure all the time
walking around their house,
they'll say something and all of a
sudden Alexa will come on and go, oh,
I couldn't find a result for that.
But do you want to listen to
Ella Fitzgerald or whatever.
It's, it's always on.
It's always listening,
right?
And you can do that with anything like
this TV right here if you want it to a
few.
If I knew that TV was going to go into
the office of the deputy foreign minister
of a country hostile to our interests,
I could turn that thing into
a receiver obviously. Right.
And if I could get my hands on that
before delivery, that's a wonderful thing.
Now I've got this in there and it's like
the old days when you would have to go
in on a,
an entry operation and you know,
you silent drills and
put a device in the wall.
Now you know, we've delivered a TV.
Now I get no, I get it right. You know,
video too. Hey, good for me.
So that Shit's always on in a,
in a sense.
And
so a regular phone that you get if you
just buy an iPhone and you have Siri
turned on so we can say,
Hey Siri,
and it turns on that
phone is always listening.
Well, uh, then now we're getting in over
my head. But it could be, I mean there is,
is it possible? Is it, is it capable of
doing that? Yes. Could you do that? Um,
uh,
as an intentional Operation Chore,
is it happening because apple wants
to do it and they want to get better
understanding of consumer
preferences and things?
I have no idea that
that's above my pay grade,
but I will say from an operational
perspective, sure, yeah.
Racial perspective.
Right.
But like it would kind of be scandalous
if we found out that apple is listened
to everything that you say and then
they're sending them information to these
companies and then they're trying to
sell you whatever you were bringing.
Yeah. But it's one, it's
really, if you think about it,
it's only one step above what
they do anyway, which is, I mean,
if I go in here and I searched
Toyota, right? You know, I'm an,
I'm in the same situation, I'm fucking
inundated with Toyota mentions, right? So,
you know, it's, it's like
the next iteration of that.
And I suspect that people would,
you know,
that some folks would be outraged,
but I'll bet people would
just live with it. Right.
We seem to be willing to give
up a lot of shit, you know,
as long as we don't think that
governments doing it right, if it's,
if it's Google, if it's Google with
somebody, we seem to be fine with it.
But if it's that, fuck it. If
it's that NSA, then now our best,
but that's not who's fucking making
jack off of these things. Right?
So it's Amazon,
Google and all these companies that are
using it to sell your data to make a lot
of money. Anyway. What do you got Jamie?
Centers call for investigation
of T-mobile, sprint,
Verizon and att and t for
selling location data.
Phone companies.
Know where you are.
Lawmakers want them to stop selling that
information until they can figure out
how to tax it,
that seems,
but what do they sell in
that location data for?
They want to know how many
people are in certain areas.
Is that the idea that that's
telling you where anyone could,
you can buy that information and
find anybody's, uh, location, right?
But look, they, they, they do these
things now where there's a billboard,
they'll put a billboard up in
a, in a, in a square, right? Uh,
and you'll walk by and the billboard has
the ability to see where the eyeballs
are, right? So you'll look
and they'll say, oh yeah,
it's looking at me that billboards
looking at me. So that's a success, right?
I've scored a hit or a view. And that was
the old days. It was like, you know, how,
you know, how many clicks or how many
billboards got a camera. There's a,
there's a ability for that billboard to
sense. And again, this, I go overboard.
If I start talking technical one,
someone will call me out and say, well,
it's not exactly how it works, but
uh, in simplistic terms, yeah, it's,
it's an ability to monitor,
um, pedestrian traffic,
uh, to understand, you know, uh,
people's interests and to further refine
so that they can sell a shit better.
Make your outdoor advertising interactive.
This is putting your phone
directly up to it. It's,
this is like you committing that there,
but there is also what he's talking
about to, this is what he started with.
This guy's talking about,
what's his name again? So this,
you walk up to a phone
that's in the photo,
you hold your phone up to it,
it sends a signal to your phone.
It seems like it's always Samsung
knows it. Only Samsung phones,
maybe just a galaxy. Add this
advertising. I have a song for you.
These are galaxy ads,
but if you can do a one way transaction,
that transaction can be two
away, easily, obviously. Right.
And it has to be to some degree because
there has to be an exchange of, you know,
sort of a handshake. So I didn't know
that billboards are staring at you though.
Yeah, no, it's, it's, it's a new,
pretty crazy shit. Look, I mean, this,
you can tracking now understanding
where people are. Right? Uh,
as an example, uh, apple, uh,
you know, it used to be putting a
beacon, right? Investigations, you know,
you put a beacon on a car, right?
And you, and it was low clumsy,
but it got better and better
as you go along. You know,
now it's, now it's, it's, uh,
it's,
it's pretty remarkable,
but you can also think about
the electronics that exist in a,
in a current vehicle and a new vehicle.
You can,
every one of those has a unique signature.
So whether it's the tire pressure, uh,
indicators,
you know,
how you get in your car and it says your
left front tire is low. Right? Well,
that's a particular signal.
If I know that signal for that car,
I'll bet I can find that
car. Right? And it's like,
it's the same with all
the other electronics that
exist within a vehicle. Um,
or just in the shit that we carry around.
They've all got some kind of signature.
So I, but again, I think, you know,
most people are willing to give up a
surprising amount of privacy for whatever
reason.
Maybe because they're getting accustomed
to it and they're not shocked by shit
anymore.